public sénat et éco des ds vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle de l'empreinte
écologique du numérique avec cette
question environnement et technologie
sont ils compatibles car la pollution
numérique est une réalité même si elle
est invisible c'est ce que nous
expliquera guillaume pitron hauteur de
l'enfer numérique les datacenters sont
excessivement énergivores notamment à
cause de la climatisation nécessaire
pour les refroidir bonne nouvelle
cependant des innovations à alès
désormais la facture énergétique vous
verrez et puis sébastien missoffe le
patron de google france sera avec nous
nous dira comment google s'y prend pour
atteindre son objectif zéro carbone en
2030 mais d'abord tout ce qu'il faut
savoir sur l'empreinte écologique de la
tech en une minute c'est parti le
numérique c'est pas bon pour la planète
vraiment
c'est moins de courrier moins de papier
moins de déplacements mais dans le même
temps le digital engendre des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre l'érosion de la
biodiversité ou des déchets
électroniques
quel impact sur le climat au niveau
mondial le numérique est responsable de
4 % des émissions de co2 soit une fois
et demi plus que l'aviation civile et
une empreinte qui pourrait doubler en
2025 et la france dans tout ça la
pollution numérique représente 2,5 pour
cent des émissions de co2 soit
l'équivalent du trafic aérien au dessus
de notre sol et la circulation de 13
millions de voitures à qui la faute
surtout aux smartphones ordinateurs
télévisions à l'origine de 80% des
émissions de co2 les data center en
gendreu 14% des émissions enfin les
réseaux informatiques nous sont
responsables que de 5% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre
et si le plus grand ennemi du climat
n'était pas la voiture ou l'avion mais
l'écran nos écrans bonjour guillaume
bonjour david jacquot guillaume pitron
journaliste et auteur de l'enfer
numérique voyage au bout d'un lac aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent alors pc
smartphones tablettes quand on vous lit
on se dit que le numérique c'est le
numérique c'est un enfer pour la planète
pour l'environnement est-ce que vous n'y
allez pas un petit peu fort parce que
finalement le numérique c'est 4 % des
émissions globales de gaz à effet de
serre on pourrait se dire ok c'est
beaucoup mais peut-être intéressons nous
aux 96 % générés par les transports par
le bâtiment par l'industrie non oui mais
si on fait ça on relativise tout et
quand on relativise on y finalement donc
moi le relativisme est un peu un
nihilisme donc je pense qu'il faut
regarder en face chaque poste de
pollution et savoir comment on peut les
améliorer et se pose de pollution là qui
suit la pollution numérique s'impose de
pollution qui est non seulement
important 4 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est quand même plus que
l'ensemble du secteur civil aérien
mondial et puis surtout c'est le poste
de pollution qui croît le plus vite
puisque l'industrie numérique et celle
qui est également croît le plus vite et
à ce rythme là en 2025 on a doublé cette
pollution là donc je crois que c'est
vraiment un des grands chapitres de la
pollution humaine qui s'ouvre ici avec
cette nouvelle pollution numérique je
crois que ça ce qu'il faut prendre à
bras le corps maintenant et quand on
regarde l'empreinte en eau en matériaux
en énergie de l'ensemble de l'industrie
numérique mondiale tout ça c'est le trip
d'un pays comme la france et là on se
dit ok mais en même temps c'est pas si
démesuré puisqu'on a comme 5 milliards
de personnes qui sont connectés au web
dans le monde alors en un sens
effectivement c'est vrai je veux dire
après tout on pourrait dire ce n'est que
encore une fois c'est une empreinte
matériel qui est quand même très forte
18 décembre dans une mine pour se rendre
compte qu est ce que c'est que l'impact
écologique du mines un téléphone
portable aujourd'hui c'est combien de
métaux à l'intérieur 50 60 70 78 métaux
donc c'est 78 mines différentes mines
pour lesquelles il a fallu des
infrastructures de l'électricité les
métaux il a fallu et raffiné et des
impacts écologiques qui sont très lourd
donc à une empreinte matériel que vous
avez donnée qui réel et puis après il ya
tout ce que ça génère comme comme revues
comme comme dégâts directs et indirects
donc on est comme dans une technologie
qui est dite immatérielle on parle de
cloud en réalité c'est très mat asia sac
à dos sagesse en sac le virtuel en fait
c'est d'abord du matériel et cette
économie dématérialisée elle est douce
sophie matériel j'espère qu'on nous suit
ça que c'est contre intuitif c'est
complètement contre intuitif parce que
qui est déjà descendu dans la soute du
net je dire quand on envoie un email
lemay qui passe par où ils passent par
des datacenter les centres de stockage
de données il passe peut-être par des
satellites le plus souvent par des
câbles sous-marins mais qui est descendu
dans cette soupe d'une est composé de
tout c'est de tous et de toutes ces
infrastructures là pas grand monde
finalement donc nous avons une relative
méconnaissance voire totale
méconnaissance de ce qu'il ya derrière
nos vies dématérialisée censément
virtuel est en fait tout cela c'est 1 1
une occupation de territoires c'est un
un coût matériel c'est un coût en termes
d'émissions de co2 de consommation
d'électricité et finalement toute cette
idée qu'on va dématérialisée nos
existences des matériels et les fiches
de paye mettre nos données dans le nuage
dans un cloud tout ça c'est complètement
faux en fait parce que derrière il ya
une infrastructure il y ajoute encore
datacenter d'ailleurs ces polluants un
datacenter saleh passé odeurs dans un
data center c'est un hangar qui peut
faire la taille de cette pièce dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons il peut
faire aussi la taille de l'immeuble et
dans cet espace là il ya des serveurs et
les saveurs dans lesquels sont stockés
traiter les données et ses serveurs qui
calcule et ses serveurs selon qu'ils
sont plus petit plus un petit ou grand
il y en a aujourd'hui 3 millions sur
terre et nous vous moi david tous les
jours somme permet en permanence
connectés avec 100 serveurs par jour
pour nos actions quotidiennes et ses
serveurs il doit fonctionner en
permanence parce que si jamais il ya une
interruption de service mais en fait y'a
plus internet et ça c'est insupportable
pour le consommateur et donc ses
serveurs tournent en permanence et en
réalité il faut beaucoup d'électricité
pour les faire fonctionner l'électricité
qu'on produit notamment et du charbon du
gaz naturel du pétrole les énergies
renouvelables et donc c'est aussi là qui
a un impact écologique si j'ai envie de
laïcs et guillaume pitron parce que
j'aime bien son livre de paul doumer
mais imaginons c'est une hypothèse c'est
quoi le parcours mondial encore une fois
d'un like alors vous êtes en face de moi
eh bien d'abord le like il va rejoindre
problement le thème 4g qui se trouve au
dessus de l'immeuble ensuite le signal
va descendre le long des des fibres delà
de la fibre qui en fait le fil par les
parties communes rejoindre le trottoir
sous les saouler sous les pas des
passants il va ensuite rejoindre un
câble en cuivre pour quelques temps
encore puisque orange va changer que
vous savez ces câbles de cuivre par des
câbles en fibres et puis il a rejoint
d'autres câbles cela il devra ensuite
problement traverser l'océan atlantique
par un câble sous marin est stocké dans
plusieurs centres de données côtes
américains parce qu'il a probablement
été émis sur un réseau social américain
il va faire son chemin inverse dans
l'autre sens à 200 mille kilomètres
seconde jusqu'à vous donc en un rien de
temps le lay qui aura parcouru des
milliers de kilomètres donc guillaume
pitron cette pollution numérique elle et
elle est réelle mais elle est et
l'invisible et c'est ça qui pose
problème en fait en fait ce qu'il peut
dire qu'on ne la voit pas et donc on
n'est pas capable de dire ah bah tiens
une action numérique elle pollue rouler
en voiture diesel c'est très concret en
termes de pollution et on le subit
immédiatement parce qu'on respire ce
qu'on produit or là on ne le voit pas on
ne le sent pas ce sont des
infrastructures dont j'ai parlé qui sont
souvent stratégique vital en cas de
guerre qu'est ce qui est qu'est-ce qui
sautent le premier sous les coups d'une
requête c'est un datacenter qu'est ce
qui est le premier coupé par un acte
malveillant c'est un câble donc en fait
on rit on garde ses structures et ses
infrastructures extrêmement discrète les
gars femmes ont pas forcément tous envie
de rappeler qu'ils évoluent d'abord dans
un monde matériel on les voit partout
sur la toile mon nez voile nulle part
dans le monde physique parce que
rappeler que derrière google facebook
amazon il y à toutes ces infrastructures
polluantes s'est aussi rappelé leur lors
leur leur contribution ou non aux
accords de paris à la transition
écologique et donc il y aussi une
logique d'un visibilisation tout ça
c'est aussi organisé une certaine
manière et donc du coup on est
complètement tenus à l'écart de cette
réalité matérielle là on n'a pas la
perception sensorielle de cette
pollution elle promet des enjeux c'est
de nous éduquer à cela après
consommateurs ce qui veut l'usagé cia
cette quête de vitesse d'instantanéité
on veut tous avoir en temps réel et la
rose d'effectivement pour la planète
c'est pas top en fait nous voulons tout
tout de suite vous savez le drame il est
là quelques pas mais complètement moi
j'en suis persuadé vous savez vous êtes
un rond point et puis vous allez avec
votre le vous laisser guider par votre
google maps et vous allez sortir à la
deuxième sortie par la troisième parce
qu'il ya un décalage entre là où vous
trouver là où google maps vous dit que
vous trouvez vous allez hurler contre la
machine parce qu'elle a une seconde de
retard ce qu'on appelle la latence et la
latence david jacquot cette
insupportable personne ne veut la
latence tout vu de l'immédiateté à la
micro seconde près si possible et tout
le monde veut un internet tout le temps
disponible 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 et si jamais il ya un top son service
qu'on a vu récemment avec facebook six
heures d'interruption de service c'est
cataclysmique dans le monde de
l'internet et donc pour éviter cela et
bien on multiplie infrastructures on les
redoute comme on dit volailles sont pas
dans un endroit ils sont donc peut-être
deux trois quatre cinq peut-être
davantage d'endroits sur la planète de
sorte que l'infrastructure est toujours
hyper disponibles et ça ça a un coût
écologique est donc ce qui coûte
écologiquement c'est de vouloir tout
tout le temps tout le match après les
bienfaits de la tête qu'on va pas les
contester évidemment absolument un
thermostat connectés dans une maison ça
permet d'économiser de l'énergie quand
on voit en somme ça évite pour le boulot
de faire un voyage polluants en avion ça
d'accord là dessus ah mais je suis
totalement d'accord l'internet le
numérique en général permet d' immense
gain écologique qu'il faut bien le
rappeler ce qu'il y à ce que l'industrie
numérique souvent insiste sur ses gains
là et on oublie de dire qu'en face des
gains il ya aussi des coûts est toute la
question c'est celle du sol de
finalement et envisage aussi parce que
quand on écoute certes le lobby européen
du numérique il affirme que le numérique
va entraîner 10 à 15 fois plus d'effets
bénéfiques que d'effets néfastes sur
l'environnement est ce que bon c'est un
lobby évidemment mais on sait pas au
final vous avez répondu c'est un lobby
comment est-ce qu'on peut être à la fois
juge et partie de ses propres actions ce
qu'il faudrait c'est donc une étude des
ailes à balles en sept manches
indépendante et donc ce qui est affirmé
par ces lobbys là je suis absolument
persuadé après deux ans d'enquêté aux
quatre coins du monde sur le voyage d'un
like que c'est faux en réalité personne
ne sait et l'honnêteté me conduit à vous
dire que je ne sais pas quel est le
solde entre ce que ça rapporte est ce
que ça coûte avant l'avènement pour la
planète le numérique et je crois qu'il
faudrait avoir tous l'honnêteté de dire
qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas parce
qu'on n'a pas assez de recul parce que
c'est un sujet tout nouveau nom qu'on
commence à s'emparer pour cela il faut
je pense commencer à réfléchir à l'usagé
du téléphone portable c'est ceux qui
polluent le plus la plus grande
pollution du numérique c'est d'abord les
fabrications abl d'interrogations et
l'usagé téléphone portable faut les
conserver plus longtemps il faut les
conserver plus longtemps en fait ils
durent environ deux ans en france à peu
près il faudrait qu'il dure quatre ans
moi j'ai acheté un iphone 7 d'occasions
donc ils avaient déjà été utilisés avant
ensuite il ne jure entre même ingéré
père est géré par être quatre fois déjà
et il peut encore durer deux ou trois
ans et donc et peut-être même davantage
donc il ya vraiment cet enjeu de garder
ces outils le plus longtemps possible
c'est d'abord ça la clé
numérique plus responsable allez merci
merci guillaume pitron donc merci david
journaliste et auteur de l'enfer
numérique voyage au bout d'un lac aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent alors on
l'a vu les data center sont
particulièrement énergivores
heureusement des solutions existent pour
réduire leur impact manuel lettre
toutes nos données numériques photos
mails transitent par des câbles sur
terre sous la mer mais aussi dans de
gigantesques datacenter ces hangars hors
norme rempli de serveurs et disques durs
il y en aurait environ 4800 répartis sur
la planète
le souci c'est que ces installations
informatiques fonctionnent 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 et pour éviter la
surchauffe des normes climatiseurs sont
déployés une aberration à l'heure où la
question écologique est au centre des
préoccupations
quel impact sur la planète ces data
center aurons dans les années à venir
comment les rendre plus écologique
aujourd'hui on construit des états
center toutes les semaines certains data
center représente une consommation
comparable à la production quasiment
d'une d'une centrale nucléaire toutes
les éoliennes françaises ne suffirait
pas à alimenter les datacenter de france
et on projette de multiplier par 4 à peu
près cette consommation d'ici 10 ans 40%
de la facture d'électricité d'un
datacenter servirait à alimenter les
serveurs et les 60% restants à les
refroidir avec des climatiseurs géant
du côté d'annecy à l'abri des regards
une entreprise développe un nouveau
système ingénieux qui rend la
climatisation obsolète un serveur sachot
et aujourd'hui quand on fait un
datacenter qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait
un datacenter qui va faire entre 5 et 7
mètres de haut d'accord on va avoir des
faux plancher on va voir des faux
plafonds on va avoir un système de clip
on va avoir un système de circulation
d'air des ailefroide d une chose tout ça
pour quoi pour refroidir dans un serveur
un point chaud
serge le fondateur de l'entreprise a
décidé de changer de paradigme en
partant d'un constat simple
si j'avais une coupe de champagne dans
maman prenons un petit peu d'imagination
et que cette coupe de champagne je veux
la refroidir qu'est ce que je fais je
refroidi le champagne ou se refroidit
toute la pièce dans lequel ea le
champagne on refera ni le champagne
l'image peut surprendre les composants
électroniques les serveurs et leur
connectique complexes sont plongés dans
un bain d'huile comme dans une sorte de
friteuse sans que le matériel
informatique ne soit altérée l'huile est
un liquide non conducteurs qui absorbent
jusqu'à 1500 fois plus de chaleur que
l'eire grâce à un circuit de
refroidissement
l'huile est maintenu à 17 degrés un
système qui dans trois ans pourrait
avoir un impact direct sur notre planète
si tout le monde à ta center city on
passerait de 20 % de l'électricité
mondiale à 4 % ce qui veut dire que on
économiserait la bagatelle de 1500
centrales nucléaires à un gigawatt si
pour certains l'enjeu est de refroidir
les serveurs en consommant moins
d'énergie d'autres ont préféré faire de
cette faiblesse une force nous avons
rendez vous chez carnot
initialement ça a été de proposer une
alternative vertueuse au datacenter ces
grandes usines du numérique qui aligne
des milliers d'ordinateurs qui tournent
jour et nuit le concept de carnot a été
justement de vouloir faire quelque chose
de cette chaleur de la valoriser pour
chauffer les bâtiments pour chauffer des
piscines pour chauffer des entrepôts
pour chauffer des sites industriels
arrêtez de refroidir à tout prix les
bâtiments abritant des datacenters et
réutiliser cette chaleur autrement dit
faire du déchets des uns la ressource d
autres
saluent louis
ça roule et c'est dans le garage de
l'entreprise que l'idée a vu le jour une
chaudière en apparence comme les autres
à quel peut-être à ypres est
ce qu'on trouve à l'intérieur des
chaudières c'est ce que j'ai dans les
mains des processeurs informatiques des
barrettes de ram des cartes
électroniques et c'est de cette chaleur
là la chaleur des processeurs dont on va
servir pour chauffer de l'eau à plus de
60° un modèle de chaudières comme celui
ci si on en a deux ou trois on arrive à
produire jusqu'à 50 % de l'eau chaude
nécessaire à une cinquantaine de
logements un système vertueux et
sécurisant pour les clients plutôt que
de concentrer les ordinateurs en un seul
lieu un datacenter carnot les distribuer
les décentralise directement là où la
chaleur va être bénéfique donc notre
approche à nous elle est distribuée les
serveurs ou plutôt les chaudières sont
répartis dans des dizaines de bâtiments
partout dans le monde en cas de panne ou
d' incendies une infime partie des
données seraient touchés
aujourd'hui les idées fleurissent pour
lutter contre la pollution numérique
mais l' influence de la france restent
limités la grande majorité des data
center se trouve au delà de nos
frontières
comment google s'y prend-il pour
améliorer son empreinte carbone réponse
avec sébastien me softly général de
google pour la france bonjour bonjour
david va très bien merci alors google
vise le zéro carbone d'ici 2030 ça
signifie qu'à cette échéance là vous
n'utiliserez plus aucune énergies
fossiles gaz pétrole ou charbon pour
alimenter la fois vos bureaux volé à
center mais il ya déjà un bout du chemin
qui a été fait j'imagine alors c'est un
gros bout d'ailleurs très importants' de
ré expliquer cela dans le contexte en
effet c'est un engagement qui a commencé
il ya longtemps c'est un engagement qui
a commencé il ya quinze ans qu en 2007
google avait annoncé la carboneutralité
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait compenser
autant de l'énergie carbone ou que nous
compensions c puis la neutralité
maintenant c'est zéro carbone est alors
quelle est la part du chemin qui a été
fait aujourd'hui revenu exactement à
quoi sert cet important en tant
qu'utilisateur qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement ça veut dire qu'en
2030 l'engagement est qu'à chaque fois
que vous faites une recherche sur google
chaque fois que vous regardez une vidéo
sur youtube à chaque fois que vous
envoyez un email ça va chercher des
informations sur des data center et que
100 % de l'énergie qui viennent
alimenter ses datacenter soit alimenté
avec de l'énergie décarbonée la cclat
aujourd'hui on a combien de tirs se sent
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à deux
tiers dans le monde et en europe on a
déjà cinq datacenter qui soit plus de
90% et aujourd'hui pas d'électricité à
base de charbon ou bien encore un petit
peu alors c'est vraiment au cas par cas
pas ces éléments de réponse là non mais
au niveau global en effet on est à deux
tiers d'énergie des câbles pour arriver
à ce 100% d'énergies vertes et ce zéro
carbone ça sera encore difficile les
deux tiers du chemin qui reste à
parcourir avec de l'innovation avec
[Musique]
la dernière partie est évidemment la
partie la plus difficile la première
partie et on le voit c'est facile
d'avoir de l'énergie décarbonée 1 quand
il ya du soleil quand il ya du vent la
difficulté est intelligent il y en a pas
tout le temps et que c'est difficile de
stocker cette information donc pour y
arriver il ya deux grandes briques la
première brique ces désinvestissements
il n'y a pas suffisamment aujourd'hui
d'énergie décarbonée pour pouvoir venir
fournir l'énergie à tous et tous ces
data center et donc c'est de continuer à
investir pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur ces 6 milliards d'euros qui ont
été investis pour mettre plus de ces
énergies là aujourd'hui sur le marché on
a annoncé l'année dernière pour
l'allemagne que on signe un grand
partenariat avec angie avec de l'énergie
éolienne et solaire en plus ce qui nous
permettra d'arriver cette année en
allemagne à 80 % d'énergies décarbonées
dans nos structures en a marre et notre
le premier enjeu c'est l'investissement
et le deuxième c'est l'innovation c'est
la technologie en la technologie qu'est
ce que c'est c'est de faire en sorte
avec l'intelligence artificielle qu'on
arrive avec des calculs plus rapide
aujourd'hui pour un même calcul on
arrive à être cette fois plus efficace
que ce qu'on était il ya cinq ans on
essaye de faire en sorte sur b
calcul des machine learning qui n'ont
pas besoin d'être fait à une aire
spécifique si vous cherchez un mot si on
a besoin de rajouter des mots
spécifiques pour google traduction on va
utiliser le moment où on est sûr d'avoir
de l'énergie décarbonée en abondance
pour utiliser ce moment là donc choisir
les bons moments de la journée et enfin
énormément d'investissement sur des
batteries pour mieux évoquer cette
énergie la fabrication d'un d'un serveur
ça concentrent 80% de la facture
énergétique d'où la question que me
posez c'est est-ce que vous communiquer
sur l'impact carbone de vaud datacenter
sur l'ensemble du cycle de vie et pas
uniquement au moment où vous les
utilisez est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous regardez ce qu'elle vous
communiquer alors on pourra regarder
j'ai pas les chiffres je ne sais pas
quelle est la source des chiffres que
vous évoquez mais ce que vous évoquez
qui est la question est évidemment
fondamental sur ce sujet c'est les
différentes villes l on doit s'engager
le niveau ans et au terme de
consommation de l'énergie évidemment
aussi les 2 et 3 sur lequel on doit
s'engager dans un télescope de lescop
trois exactement savoir encore une fois
sur le de l'ensemble du cycle de vie
l'énergie qu'on a utilisé pour fabriquer
datacenter ou pour le détruire derrière
est ce que 3c lusage des clients et des
fournisseurs pardon être précis sur vous
êtes imbattable
sur ces sujets et donc sur ce sujet là
sur ce point sur les autres scoops on
s'engage cette net neutralité c'est à
dire de compenser en termes d'énergie ce
qui a été utilisé pour la fabrication de
ses datacenters
l'impact environnemental d'un data scène
heures ça se résume pas évidemment
uniquement sa facture d'électricité est
aussi une grosse consommation d'eau ça
on le sait elle augmente aussi
rapidement votre consommation d'eau et
quel impact vous regarder l'impact
s'assure sur les sols sur la faune sur
l'affluence est juste quand vous
regardez sur lequel vous communiquer
aussi l'eau est utilisé aujourd'hui pour
refroidir les data center sur ça ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est d'abord
de voir que chaque datacenter des
réponses un peu différente ça dépend de
nous on est si on arrive à récolter des
autres pluie quel type de on peut
utiliser et sur cet engagement
spécifique autour de l'eau notre
engagement est de faire en sorte qu'on
remet 120% de ce qu'on a consommé c'est
à dire plus d'eau dans le système avec
des accords qu'on fait localement avec
des stations d'épuration pour remettre
plus de dents dans l'écosystème alors
entre zéro carbone c'est l'objectif
évidemment et donc utiliser des sources
d'électricité éolienne ou solaire pour
alimenter les serveurs il faut ce qu'on
appelle des métaux stratégiques il faut
du lithium du cuivre du cobalt dont
l'extraction on le sait porte atteinte à
la biodiversité à l'environnement vous
vous assurez vous chez google que tous
ces mets ton était extrait de manière
durable de manière responsable vous
regardez ça aussi oui alors on a un
certain nombre des chartes avec chacun
des fournisseurs avec lequel on
travaille qui est un point important et
puis les engage avec un engagement et
ensuite ce qui est important aussi de
réfléchir la durée de vie
par exemple sur les téléphones nokia un
engagement sur lequel on travaille mais
ce qui est très important c'est de faire
en sorte que quand vous achetez un
téléphone on puisse continuer à mettre
les mises à jour des différents software
pendant au moins cinq ans qui contribue
à permettre aux utilisateurs conservait
je vois à conserver leurs vieux telle
entre guillemets l'impunité il se trouve
que tout est conservé on le sait dans
les datacenter nos vieux mail datant de
20 ans une vidéo de chat qu'on a fait
qu'on a posté sur youtube il ya dix ans
est ce que on sait que tout ce stockage
ça consomme l'énergie sébastien missoffe
pour tout ça pour une utilité qui est
discutable il ya des bas mais c'est vrai
est ce que vous regardez ça aussi
longtemps les consommateurs le souhaite
puisque c'est vraiment important de
conserver sa aussi longtemps vous ouvrez
votre compte gmail vous pouvez voir
combien d'informations sont stockées et
tous ces éléments là nous aide à faire
des choix rationnels mais toutes
ces chiffres que nous taillon nous
permettent en suisse est comme ça quand
les responsabiliser quelque part les
utilisateurs en montrant voilà voilà
tout ce stockage que ça coûte en excès
cité en faire sans devoir le stocker les
informer et les responsabiliser et
ensuite de l'autre côté en termes de
technologie être capable d'être créatif
de continuer à investir ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur la
puissance de calcul qui nous permet de
stocker ces informations avec de moins
en moins d'énergie mais ça fait changer
de comportement c'est suffisant pour
faire évoluer les comportements ce n'est
pas votre rôle encore une fois l'idée
séduit d'éduquer entre guillemets à la
une forme de sobriété numérique en
matière de pollution c'est qu'il ya une
pollution qui est lié à numérique est
source de solutions qui est source de
pollution parce que la vie n'est pas
pénible en chinois alors sur la
pollution numérique est vraiment pour
moi ces deux jambes sur le khalife au
marché la première s'est en effet montré
les idées aux utilisateurs quel est
l'impact est un travail d'éducation qui
est vraiment absolument important et
puis la deuxième la technologie peut
aussi aider à cette sobriété numérique
sauf qu'un des exemples est plus
intéressant c'est que si vous regardez
aujourd'hui une vidéo sur youtube selon
vous la regardiez chez vous sur du wifi
ou sur du 4k dans un métro on va savoir
adapter la qualité de la vidéo en
fonction de là où vous êtes du type d'
usage de l'écran que vous regardez et
donc de contribuer à cette sobriété
numérique allez merci beaucoup sébastien
missoffe directeur général de google
france merci hier six locaux et pour
réduire la pollution numérique qui la
solution passe aussi par un changement
de nos comportements vous allez voir
et oui on peut agir au quotidien pour
réduire son impact bonjour amis dans la
vie alors ça peut sembler être une
goutte d'eau dans un océan mais tout ça
mis bout à bout ça peut faire la
différence alors vous l'avez dit cette
pollution numérique elle est invisible
fixés assez abstrait pour se rendre
compte sachez qu envoyer un mail revient
à laisser une ampoule allumée pendant 24
heures à l'échelle d'une entreprise de
100 salariés sur un an ça pollue autant
que 14 aller retour paris new york et
puis au niveau de la planète en
seulement une heure nous consommons
autant que quinze centrales nucléaires
et la crise sanitaire avec l'essor du
télétravail ne rien arranger évidemment
ah c'est vrai que depuis deux ans on
assiste à une augmentation vertigineuse
de nos mails de nos partage de documents
ou encore de nos réunions en
visioconférence la visioconférence qui
d'ailleurs est redoutable il faut savoir
qu'une heure de vidéo qu'on fait mais et
1 kg de dioxyde de carbone selon une
étude de l'université de yale donc un
conseil éteignez vos caméras est passé
en audio si vous le pouvez alors emilie
justement vous avez compiler les bons
gestes pour nous pour nous aider à nous
améliorer et le premier concerne les
recherches sur le web il faut savoir
qu'une recherche sur google ces sept
grammes de co2 dans l'atmosphère quand
on sait que 3,5 milliards de requêtes
sont faites chaque jour vous imaginez
les dégâts alors le mieux finalement
c'est de taper directement l'url dans sa
barre de recherche en tout cas si vous
disposez bien de votre adresse url selon
l'ademe ont divisé par quatre quand même
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est vrai que ça peut paraître
fastidieux pour gagner du temps vous
pouvez pourquoi pas enregistré dans vos
favoris les adresses web vous avez
l'habitude d'aller et puis pour le reste
elle a essayé de limiter vos recherches
au strict nécessaire alors pour se
donner bonne conscience emilie certains
ferment leurs pages web ouvertes ou
régulièrement ville de leur boîte mail
ce que ça sert une pas quelque chose
alors certains vous diront que c'est une
goutte dans l'océan il n'empêche c'est
fondamental de fermer les pages dont
vous n'avez plus besoin car même si
elles sont inactives les navigateurs les
réactualisée en permanence ce qui
réactive toute la chaîne des data center
pour rien bon vous n'avez pas répondu
sur le ménage de sa boîte mail ça vaut
le coup alors alors c'est toujours la
même histoire à ses milliers de vieux
mais de vieux spam qui n'ont absolument
aucune utilité pour vous font tourner
donc des serveurs un peu partout sur la
planète donc oui il faut faire la vie
prend l'habitude de faire le ménage tout
comme d'ailleurs se désabonner des
newsletters que vous lisez et puisqu'on
parle de vos mails sachets alléger vos
échanges il faut savoir quand on envoie
une pièce jointe c'est la cata quand on
signe avec un logo également pensé à
envoyer envoyer vos pdf en basse
définition à utiliser une clé usb ou
tout simplement oui transfert qui ne
stocke les données que sur une donnée
une durée limitée enfin n'oubliez pas
que quand vous cliquez sur répondre à
tous et autant de mails envoyés que le
nombre de dessinateurs et donc autant de
serveurs monopolisé et que mettre
quelqu'un en copie c'est comme envoyer
six grammes de co2 dans l'atmosphère un
mot de l'a4 âges et milieux de la 5g qui
sont également parfois pointé du doigt à
tort ou à raison alors il vaut mieux
utiliser le wifi clairement parce que le
wifi consomme 23 fois moins
d'électricité que la cage et donc quand
vous arrivez chez vous pensez bien à
activer le wifi sur votre smartphone bon
dernier mot sur le streaming vidéo n'a
jamais autant regardé de série nous
toutes et tous g vous avez gardé david
le pire pour la fin le streaming c'est
la plus énergivore de nos activités
numériques toujours selon l'ademe il est
responsable à lui seul de 1 % des
émissions de co2 dans l'atmosphère pour
se rendre compte regardez à l'est 10
minutes une vidéo en haute définition
sur son smartphone ça revient à utiliser
un four de 2000 watts à pleine puissance
pendant cinq minutes donc j'ai dit c'est
évidemment pas d'arrêter la série mais
plutôt d'agir aller avec bon sens on
peut par exemple opté pour un format sd
plutôt que hd on peut aussi désactiver
la lecture automatique dans les
paramètres de l'api et puis évidemment
télécharger sa vidéo plutôt que de la
regarder en direct ça consommera
nettement moins d'énergie donc à d il ya
des bons gestes à adopter mercy emilie
merci pourvu que ça dure les missions
qui rend les co-responsables c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui magazine avoir au
revoir sur public sénat il ya du replay
sur publicsenat.fr en et vous dans
quinze jours
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien décoder ds
[Musique]